>> IT IS STRAINING THE LIMB LIMF
OUR ABILITY TO PROVIDE FOR NEW
YORKERS IN NEED AND RUNNING
THROUGH OUR BUDGET.
WE EXPECT TO SPEND $1 BILLION BY
THE END OF THE FISCAL YEAR ON
THIS CRISIS.
WILL:NY CITY ERIC ADAMS
DECLARING A STATE OF EMERGENCY
AS 17,000 MIGRANTS BUSSED TO THE
BIG APPLE IN RECENT MONTHS AND
THE DEMOCRAT PLEADING WITH
PRESIDENT BIDE TON TAKE ACTION
AS THE CITY IS SET TO SPEND
$1 BILLION THIS YEAR.
HERE TO REACT IS NEW YORK
REPRESENTATIVE NICOLE
MALLIOTAKIS.
CONGRESSWOMAN, GREAT TO HAVE YOU
ON THE PROGRAM.
I'M CURIOUS, WHEN YOU HEAR MAYOR
ADAMS AND HIS TONE RHETORIC AND
THE WORDS HE'S USING, DO YOU
HEAR A LACK OVAL WINDOW
SELF-AWARENESS OR HYPOCRISY OR A
LEADER BEGINNING TO SEE THE
LIGHT?
>> WELL, I THINK HE'S BEGINNING
TO SEE THE LIGHT BECAUSE THIS IS
ABSOLUTELY UNSUSTAINABLE AND IT
IS PLACING A TREMENDOUS BURDEN
ON THE PEOPLE OF NEW YORK CITY.
$1 BILLION AT A TIME WHEN NEW
YORKERS CAN'T AFFORD TO KEEP
THEIR OWN ROOFS OVER THEIR HEAD
AND STRUGGLING TO PAY FOR FOOD
WITH THIS HIGH INFLATION.
BUT THE MAYOR IS ALSO
HYPOCRITICAL BECAUSE HE REFUSES
TO ADDRESS NEW YORK CITY'S
SANCTUARY STATUS PREDOMINANTLY
THE PART THAT PROHIBITS NYP FROM
EVEN COOPERATING WITH
DEPORTATION IF A INDIVIDUAL
COMMITS A CRIME HERE IN NEW YORK
CITY.
BUT IN THE WHOLE SPEECH HE NEVER
CALLED FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN TO
SECURE THE BORDER.
HE CALLED FOR A DECOMPRESSION OF
THE BORDER.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS.
HE NEEDS TO TELL PRESIDENT BIDEN
TO SECURE THE BORDER, STOP THE
NONSENSE AND BRING BACK THE
POLICIES UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP
THAT WERE WORKING.
WILL: TO YOUR POINT, LET'S TAKE
A QUICK LOOK AT WHAT HE HAD TO
SAY AND I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT, HE
NEGLECTED TO GET DOWN TO BRASS
TAX TO BE SPECIFIC BUT, BOY,
HE'S FLIRTING WITH GETTING TO
THE ISSUE.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> THE TIME TO AID NEW YORK IS
NOW.
WE KNEAD HELP FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
HELP FROM THE STATE OF NEW YORK
AND CONGRESS MUST PASS EMERGENCY
FINANCIAL RELIEF FOR OUR CITY.
WE NEED A BIPARTISAN EFFORT TO
DELIVER LONG AWAITED IMMIGRATION
REFORM SO WE CAN OFFER PEOPLE A
SAFE AND LEGAL PATH TO THE
AMERICAN DREAM.
WILL: AS HE'S SPEAKING.
HE HAS A POWER POINT NEXT TO HIM
SAYING FEDERAL ACTION. ACTION.
I DO WONDER, YOU KNOW, THE PLAN
BY RON DESANTIS AND GREG ABBOTT
AND BORDER STATE GOVERNORS WHO
SENT ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS TO
PLACES LIKE NEW YORK CITY TO
MAKE THEM SEE THE LIGHT, IT DOEN
THE VERGE OF SAYING SECURE THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> WELL, WHAT I'LL SAY IS THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAD BEEN FLYING
234 INDIVIDUALS FOR A LONG TIME
NOW AND HE DIDN'T SAY ANYTHING
ABOUT IT AND NEITHER DID OUR
GOVERNOR.
IN FACT, THEY'VE INCENTIVIZED
THIS CRISIS BY OFFERING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS SO MANY DIFFERENT
BENEFITS.
BENEFITS IN SOME CASES THAT
AMERICAN CITIZENS DON'T EVEN
RECEIVE SO FOR EXAMPLE, CATHY
HOCHUL WANTED TO GIVE
UNEMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE OR
STIMULUS CHECKS TO THOSE IN THE
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY AND CREATED A
FUND FOR THAT .
IF YOU WERE A SINGLE MOTHER OF
THREE, YOU EARN $100,000 IN NEW
YORK, YOU GOT NOTHING FROM CATHY
HOCHUL AND SAME THING WITH
HEALTHCARE BENEFITS FOR SENIORS
HERE ILLEGALLY AND OUR SENIOR
CITIZENS ARE STRUGGLING.
THE ONE THING IS WE'RE NOT
GETTING ANY ACTION TILL
REPUBLICANS TAKE BACK THE HOUSE.
THAT'S EVIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT CREATED THIS
CRISIS, THE VICE PRESIDENT
IGNORED THIS CRISIS AND NANCY
PELOSI AND CHUCK SCHUMER WON'T
BRING ANYTHING TO THE FLOOR FOR
A VOTE.
WE NEED TO FLIP THE HOUSE, END
ONE PARTY RULE IN NEW YORK AS
WELL AND THAT'S THE ONLY WAY
WE'LL GET ACTION ON THIS.
WILL: